depuis aujourd'hui on se trouve sur aude
ait aujourd'hui on va voir un rendez
vous romantique avec un chien jeux mots
t'es jaloux on y va alors c'est en
anglais malheureusement mais je pouvoir
vous traduire ça avec mes capacités
incroyables je suis dave quel est ton
nom squeeze waouh quel super non pour y
est tu te calmes le chien quel est ton
travail j'ai envie de savoir je fais ça
actuellement était pas payé non ne pas
payer là est-ce que tu as tu refais
cette taille la question de merde ça n'a
jamais beaucoup changé je suis satisfait
de ma situation actuelle moi non j'aime
beaucoup ton petit tu es un petit visage
écrasé de moguai c'est parfait ça je
n'apprécie pas trop et squeeze oh ça va
le pas d'humour roger comprends que tu
complexe sur pas mal de choses mais tu
n'as pas de raison de rejeter ça sur moi
j'suis complexe sur rien - monsieur j'ai
des gros biceps
est ce que tu aimerais voir ma
collection de de storm septembre le tout
bien chiant time's up à après c'est la
fin ok à chaque fois tu recommences en
fait d'accord j'avais pas compris
alors quel est ton nom va remettre le
même nom et ce qu'il nous reconnaît ou
pas squeeze sérieux ça ne ressemble pas
un nom mais arrête tu es adorable oyu
mais je suis né comme ça qu'est ce que
tu fais pour t'amuser
maman tu veux savoir ben oui il a un
blog et ils me demandent nous qu'est ce
qu'on fait fart on pète etc sans blague
a dit ça veut dire 'attendez faut que je
sens que je veux dire propre moi ça va
j'ai des petites lacunes bordet est ce
que tu crois aux fantômes c'est bien ça
ouais y croient aux fantômes est ce que
tu as déjà couru la moitié d'un marathon
il se met à pleurer me parle pas
d'exercices physiques ou deux trucs de
ce genre bah désolé je m'intéresse à
tous vos [ __ ] est-ce que tu familier
avec un arc et des flèches
j'aimerais que tu saches que je suis
dégoûté par cette question les arcs et
les flèches sont définitivement pas dans
mon top 10 des choses que j'apprécie
attend il fait de la merde à genève
c'est une blague non mais je peux plus
faire villefranque il faut que je fasse
avec un chien let's get up again
ah oui on peut peut-être ronger meetup
yep by auto la disquette
à chaque fois ils s'appellent brendan on
va s'appeler michael sérieusement ça ne
ressemble pas un nom est-ce que tu
vivrais dans le zoo de chester je pense
que personne ne voudrait vivre ici
hockey lah pour ce faire mais merci est
ce que tu as des skips spéciaux c'est
une bonne question ça il sait faire des
triple saut tu peux deviner par mon
apparence physique mais justement non
est ce que tu as déjà pensé à changer
ton nom est allé à t'appeler hugo ouais
mec c'est tout il répond juste oui
[ __ ] mais c'est infernal
le démon est de retour name john bowman
ckoi djomo à faire genre tu joues au jeu
voilà john white annonce spéciale très
spéciale tanger - une part carrément
mieux nous déjà août est allé à l'école
je suis pas allé à l'école je me suis
fait tout seul quand je vivais dans une
cave
abbas est ce que tu as déjà lu aux euro
est-elle en train dire qu'ils nous
aiment d'accord ok c'est un mégot la
littérature apparemment je voyais ça
sent carrément mieux que nous alors
qu'il est totalement en train de se
mettre bien là-bas quoi est-ce que tu m
entends des blagues c'est bien ça oh
[ __ ] et l'on doit choisir une blague
pourquoi vélo on ne peut pas rester
droit parce qu'il est trop fatigué waouh
c'est une blague incroyable tu dois
tellement fier je devrais écrire ce nul
le chien est ce que tu es déjà allé au
kilimandjaro et jumbo marché ne me rends
pas malade
adacore merde ça on a perdu les points
du coup bah en fait c'est en fait un
groupe port de chiens qui veut pas faire
d'exercice physique
sauvé par la cloche à temps où
commençait bien on a finit mal lui
s'appelle douglas et ben on va s'appeler
douglas aussi tout cela sérieusement ça
ne ressemble pas un nom je lui ai donc
toi connard et c'est d'avoir super
pouvoirs qu'est ce que ce serait
d'accord il dit je me sens déjà comme un
super héros je pense qu'on est tous des
super héros au fond de nous as tu déjà
lu iron man assez bien ça au port une
seconde j'ai pensé que c'était cool
désolé mais non aaa
il est jaloux c'est tout le suisse et un
sombrero claquette un vieux chien avec
de la graisse et tout est ce que tu vois
ma collection de portraits de moi même
je devrai bien sûr que je veux
j'aimerais une collection de vias et le
fit il est détestable ce chien au bordel
les cafés pas de conneries je te vois
est ce que tu as des surnoms ils
m'appellent le dragon cactus vraiment
lol ouais t'as pas à rigoler de moi où
est ton sens de la morale espèce de
dégénéré à tanger tétouan et j'ai envie
j'en peux plus de ce schème rend fou en
plus y'a lui s'est allié avec john ball
vais me rendre complètement fou look et
surtout il s'appelle negar donc nous on
va s'appeler fdp fait psa fort arrêt
auquel je demande si on rouvre une
blague
ils me répondent qu'ils détestent les
blagues tétouan et écoute c'est que je
me repose pourquoi une orange à rethel
de courir parce qu'elle n'a plus de jus
voilà c'était excellent vraiment une
très bonne blague
est ce que tu veux entendre une blague à
l'injure en super lourd warhol on lui
proposait de faire un max de blague
qu'est ce que tu appelles un loser à
celui qui nous fait black cette fois
fait p lololol fait p c'est le nom
qu'ont appris au début c'est excellent
site a déjà pensé à changer ton m en
bertrand pas moyen à bertrand c'est
sympa mais bert ont même eu l'air
d'apprécier
qu'est ce que tu fais pour le fun il est
dj mais il trouve pas ça spécialement
fun et me demande moi qu'est ce qui est
fun faire des vidéos pour mes abonnés
d'amour
voit aussi on a beaucoup de choses en
commun bvc truquée youtuber c'est génial
est ce que tu es déjà allé dans l'espace
qui est hors de question est-ce donc
voyager dans l'espace sérieusement
dégage tout mais c'est violent je te
raconte une blague c'est très lourd à
live à 10 dont j'avais ma à quoi tu
penses on lui demande s'il pense à nous
il a dit ça c'est oui je rigole je pense
un pot de crème brûlée
pourquoi les rockeurs se finissent
toujours mal ce que tu as des conseils à
me donner pour que l'argent je réussisse
à faire en quarts quel genre de conseils
tu veux des concerts romantique c'est
parfait puisqu'il nous faut soit occupé
ou soit blasé c'est ce que je dis
toujours c'est pour ça que je fais des
speed dating mais c'est un conseil
affreux jurés poway mais c'est le
meilleur conseil que tu pourras que tu
auras de ta vie tu as besoin d'autre
chose gamin un conseil cool si tu veux
être un chat cool tu dois avoir des
lunettes de soleil et peut-être un béret
chez pas tentant jumbo
il m'a répondu vous avez vu aller cette
fois on se revoit ça s'est bien passé
sur la fin
[Musique]
orange anciens fin de cette vidéo sur
orange espère c'est le plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas les mecs comme d'habitude
bah voilà les rancoeurs se finissent
toujours mal que ce soit avec et vit
avec le singe avec ce chien c'est
toujours un calvaire noir un caviar à un
calvaire à la sous traitance de
prochaine du non-versement regarder
portez vous bien giotto monde bis
[Musique]